do you like my parents yes we met in
musical theater school we had a
composition class and I was basically
like oh who's this guy with little
shorts on
we're both dancers that's how we met I'm
a social worker I'm a part-time nanny so
take care of kids so I'm really good at
telling little lies my name is Jessica
Frieda I've been a polygraph examiner
for almost eight years would you stay
with me if I was broke you are and yes
no it's true you don't need me to tell
you are you always gonna be messy no
that's a lie
she's got clothes that haven't even like
to have tags gotten off she's like oh I
have this shirt I don't even know how do
you feel looking for excess on social
media yeah that's truthful you do you
told me you never do I mean okay no
that's fine
I was like tidy - have you been eating
my ice cream at night when I sleep no
[Music]
that is a sound yourself away you've
eaten the whole carton of ice cream like
four of them - have you ever thought
about another girl while we've been
having sex yes but then she wasn't real
do you think you're better dancer than
me no have you ever thought about
cheating on me
yes what a [ __ ] that's true you tell me
I mean you think about it yes what I
think about doing it yeah you think you
think about it yeah you gonna get hurt
have you ever had a secret identity no
but I wish I did that was fun I feel
like his parents play that part okay and
then the whole exes thing she would she
would she would pull me aside good I
[Music]
think I'm good with money extra you just
like spend your money on like I'm like a
lot of that's true